the ramaswami blasts CNN debate over
exclusion says only establishment
insiders will be on stage ramaswami and
former president Trump have announced
their own town hall events I wonder if
the Fox News is framing it this way
because they're doing their own town
hall I think they're doing a town hall
with Trump so on the 10th of January
timcast will be hosting a town hall
event I don't know if we can call it
it's a live stage event with a live
audience with aake and uh we're still
we're we're we're cramming this thing
together basically what happens is we
were planning on being in Iowa for the
caucus on the 15th doing a special show
it's a Monday so
it's I don't know why I work so much man
I'm out of my mind it's expensive it's
extremely difficult but we do it for you
so become a member at timcast.net
for the caucus and of course we we got
to talking to VI who's been in the show
a couple times and uh ultimately we were
like we could we could come longer and
do something uh for from the 10th to the
15th so you know what we ended up
deciding to do is our own live event
we're lucky we were able to get VI and
we will be in Iowa with v on stage
tickets are are being sold I think they
may be up now just thing's been rushed
together super quick it's probably going
to sell out super quick because there
only there's there's a very small number
of tickets available and we're going to
do our own version because I'm thinking
to myself screw CNN screw their
establishment
insiders we're going to do our event
we're going to do it and so uh uh you
know here's here's why I bring this up
for one we want we definitely want to
announce that we're doing this it's big
news V saying screw off but in the
previous segment we're were talking
about how the media frames everything
take take a look at this article from
The New York Times oh I love to be
included thank you New York Times for
writing about me thank you New York
Times for writing about right-wing
commentator
timolol VI said he would instead do a
live show with the right-wing
commentator Tim p on January 10th the
night of the debate I love that Fox News
said V will participate in his own town
hall event next week well okay maybe
they mean his own as in he's the sole
guy on the show fine we're basically
doing the show live on stage I believe
Luke and uh Sheamus will be with us as
well but uh you see how the media plays
this game Nikki Haley and Ronda santis
are the establishment choices and I
think this is why Donald Trump doesn't
want to be on those stages he he knows
they're going to set up these debates in
a way to prop up GOP and and political
insiders so surprise surprise same thing
for v v actually announced he wasn't
going to do it before CNN even announced
who was qualified so I think it's funny
that they say he blast CNN over
exclusion I think we actually have uh
let me pull up VI's tweet and uh here we
go here's the official announcement from
VI and I'll break down exactly what he
said the V ramaswami tweets forget CNN's
fake Iowa debate on January 10th which
will be the most boring in modern
history I gotta
agree I look with Chris Christie we
laugh with VI we cheer with vake Ron and
Nikki you get an interesting
establishment versus anti-establishment
dynamic dynamic with just the two of
them they're going to they're going to
be like well Nikki I agree with
everything you just said and then it's
going to be like the furama joke where
you guys remember this one uh uh was it
the two clones and he's like I think
your tax proposal goes too far well I
think your tax proposal doesn't go too
far enough it's just so boring but
anyway he says we'll do that show with
Tim Kon said we won't hold back here's
the back story on CN Shenanigans
December 13th CNN disgracefully cut
short its own Iowa town hall with me
after I correctly pointed out
uncomfortable truth about January 6
which CNN instantly dismissed as
conspiracy theories December 14th CNN
then threatened my campaign on the phone
with a cease and assist and had YouTube
black uh black out the town hall after
it got 200,000 plus views on YouTube in
a matter of hours yet Nikki Haley CNN
Town Hall was still about for 6 months 6
68k total views
sad later on the 14th CNN notified my
campaign that multiple qualifying polls
which the RNC used for each of the RNC
debates mysteriously wouldn't count for
CNN's fake debate in iow on the 10th
CNN's media uh uh CNN senior media
reporter Oliver Darcy wrote a newsletter
that castigated my his own network for
allowing me to infect the public with
his conspiracy campaign Oliver Darcy you
are an evil person I hope you know this
cuz I've I've I've known Oliver DY for a
long time I have I have met him in
person on numerous occasions we know
many of the same people but this is the
Oliver is an example of of malicious
evil malicious evil because I will tell
you uh VI is actually playing nice when
he says January 6 looks like an inside
job the fact is January 6 was an inside
job that is a fact that is not in
dispute the only reason the media is
pretending there's a dispute is because
they're lying to you case in point
Capital police officers escorted the
shaman through the building to help him
locate the Senate chambers and then open
the doors for him that does not mean
that Joe Biden and Nancy py teamed up
and colluded it means that Capital
police officers who work for the
government and our law enforcement
facilitated many of the J Sixers
Misadventures I am not talking about
Riders I am talking about the capital
police who took selfies with people got
in trouble for it that's what an inside
job is if a bank is being robbed and it
turns out one security guard opened the
door to let the robbers in we call that
an inside job so when Oliver Darcy comes
out and says it was a conspiracy theory
he is lying to you intentionally because
he knows everything I just said he is an
evil person anyway I digress commentator
van Jones said he was literally shaking
when he heard V speak and my rhetoric is
one step away from Nazi propaganda Cen
an anchor Anderson Cooper said I
delivered a soliloquy of conspiracy
theories that's just absolutely false
and not true VI actually nailed
everything perfectly and was very light
actually Cen in Anchor Pamela Brown said
uh and chief investigative correspondent
said V has a history of pedaling
disinformation they're lying anchor
Caitlyn Collin said I use reasonable
tone to sell Sinister lies to people who
aren't paying close attention and might
think what he is saying maybe is
legitimate CNN's token conservative
commentator Alysa far Griffin said my
rhetoric is damaging to the country so
that's what VI put out this morning
announcing that he will be on the
timcast live Town Hall instead and uh
look it's a crazy world but we see
through it and every day we more and
more people are waking up to what CNN
does the greatest example of this is
when Caitlyn Collins says uses a
reasonable tone to sell Sinister lies to
people who aren't paying close attention
it's fascinating that's literally what
Caitlyn Collins is doing if you are
watching CNN you're literally not paying
attention if you are reading Twitter you
are more you're paying more attention so
it's varying degrees watching CNN is the
opposite of paying atten attention it
would be
like a dude who's selling uh balance
bands and getting your medical advice
from him and he's like don't listen to
the doctors man buy my rubber bands they
protect you from from illness you're
like yeah wow could you imagine people
who didn't know the truth that's right
that's what CNN is CNN is like those
guys at the mall that you know those
Balance things they would sell no
there's a magic trick you can do uh
magicians do this to uh I love this
let's let's let's jump in so so let's
say a magician wants to uh uh uh preempt
their trick like create an idea they'll
say something like this is a magic wand
right and I can prove it watch this hold
your arms out put your feet together and
hold your arms out they'll then push
down on your arm and you'll fall over of
course he'll then say now this magic
wand it's got magic powers watch hold
out your hands he'll put the wand in
your hand and then he'll pull down but
this time no matter how hard he pulls
down you won't fall over it's called the
center of gravity illusion what you do
is the first time you you pull down you
pull away you down and to the right at a
slight slight angle the second time down
and in at a slight angle one topples one
doesn't when they're holding the magic
wand you're like see that proves them
they go wow it's magic it granted you
magic powers so what happens is these
guys start selling these these
wristbands claiming they improve your
balance and they do a literal magic
trick to trick people anyway I tell you
that because that's what CNN does
they're they're lying to your face
Oliver Darcy you're a scumbag
and he's him and Caitlin Collins and
Caitlin Collins she worked for the
caller she knows what she's doing these
people are malicious evil they know
they're lying to you for profit power
and money they're just bad people and
they're they're claiming they're they're
they're the the real the real ones
imagine finding a guy in an alley with a
bunch of syringes and he's like I'm a
doctor trust me don't trust your doctor
you'd be like wow this guy knows the
truth that's CNN it's so funny to me
listen you call Oliver Darcy an evil
person he's the guy that got Alex Jones
kicked off Twitter just because Alex was
mean to him in Congress look at those
let's clarify did Oliver Darcy get Alex
Jones kicked off or did Alex Jones get
kicked off because of what he said about
Oliver
Darcy I think Oliver Darcy was going
around complaining like actively going
and making reports and doing things like
that but but if we don't know we don't
know and Oliver helped with getting rid
of ads for Infowars and then Alex right
like kind of like you know called him
out and then the video circulated then
Twitter saw that as sometime but the
reason why I make this distinction is I
think it's more likely that all the big
tech companies colluded with each other
to remove Alex and that was the excuse
Twitter was looking for to make it
happen not if if we say Oliver Darcy did
it first of all if he didn't do it I
don't want to say he did but more
importantly I think it's it's it's
substantially more important to point
out that big Tech colluded all at the
same time to remove Alex Jones Twitter
was I think the last and it was because
they didn't have a strong enough reason
to justify it so as soon as they saw
this video they went get him so it it's
it's scarier and more
um devastating when you realize massive
multinational corporations were
conspiring as opposed to some guy we
don't like sending a email you know what
I mean I get it I just think it's it's
hilarious that we're here talking about
Oliver darc on for for what for me is a
bit like uh you know Alex Jones day
because tomorrow he's going to be his
video game Alex Jones game is going to
be on Steam so is it it's it's out
already though isn't it yeah but it's
it's going to be on Steam for the first
time tomorrow steam says it's all good
to go they had no problem with it thank
God and like and the video game is him
like fighting zombies and demons and
stuff right well he's on Epstein Island
there's a character called the
rapist uh he looks very suspiciously
like someone you might know there's
there's a character called the Wicked
Witch of the West Wing uh you know
that's are there not gay frogs there are
definitely gay frogs in the video game
gay
frogs anyway um yeah but uh so that's
what's going to be happening I don't
know what else there is to say about
this this big thing we're doing I mean
we just kind of got a whole segment
about out of the announcement that we'll
be doing this Town Hall uh with the vake
but uh it's going to be a blast we're
going to be in Iowa all uh Wednesday
Thursday Friday and then the last show
we're doing Monday you know I just want
to point out to everybody it is Bonkers
degrees of difficulty to do stuff like
this Cu uh that means Monday night at uh
like 11:00 p.m. central we have to get
on on a jet and fly back to DC and then
I got to wake up in the morning for the
morning show so it's just and we're
we're probably going to do this several
times throughout the year because this
is the year to do it man 2024 baby the
primaries are going to be hot it's big
deal I'm just really curious what
happens with like look Haley and
DeSantis are both pulling at like 10%
and it's really sad for DeSantis that
he's there was a there was a point where
DeSantis was the uh uh betting Market
favorite which is which is wild yeah and
now he's beneath Nikki Haley this is
typical of of races though I mean I
can't remember the last time uh a
president presidential candidate got in
and a year in change before the election
was the you know was leading unless they
were the incumbent you know look at look
at Barack Obama when he first came in it
took until it took a while before he
took Le I'm just going to I'm going to
I'm going to go now look let me just say
something everybody I get a lot of
people they say Tim you're so mean to
people sometimes that uh they won want
to come on your show and I'm like the
people I'm mean to I don't care if they
come on my show okay anybody I call evil
and like a scumbag you know I'm going to
call them that because that's how I feel
and if that means they don't want to
come on my show fine could you imagine
if I was like I better not call that
evil prick a scumbag because then I
won't be able to bring him on my show
for internet points sorry not interested
but let me just tell you I'm just GNA
I'm just going to say all this stuff
which I probably shouldn't say
considering but I'm going to say it
anyway someone asked why don't we get a
debate with like RFK Jr he won't do it
RFK Jr won't do it and we've we've asked
several times okay you I'll tell you
this if I if my team reaches out to you
and says would you be interested in any
one of these and they say no I got no
problem saying they will not do it okay
and there are people like yeah but if
you put them on blast for this then you
know they're never going to want to come
on your show don't care if RFK Jr
doesn't want to come on the show he
doesn't have to he doesn't owe me any
favors but if we if we Pro if we give
the potential for high-profile debates
that no one else can do or high-profile
conversations that no one else can do
and these people refuse to do it then
I'm going to point out they won't do it
they want the safety blanket that is CNN
and I'm not exaggerating I like Maran
Williamson a lot but she won't do it
either it was hard enough to get her on
the show I like her I think she's a good
person I think she's wrong about a lot
of things I think we informed her of
things she wasn't aware of and Maran
Williamson doesn't want to do outside
debates because she is scared and RFK Jr
is scared they are terrified that if
they sit down on a show like this we're
going to say Epstein list who's on it
and they're going to go uhoh if I did
CNN they'd ask me really boring and easy
questions go for it I can't wait for the
day that CNN finally closes its doors
because we get more in the key demo than
they do and then when you want to have
the debate it's going to have to be with
Steven Crowder Patrick B David Joe Rogan
Tucker Carlson or Tim cast because
sooner or later that's going to be the
game and only people like VI ramaswami
and Donald Trump because he goes on
these shows too are going to the ones
who can make it in politics but for the
time being when someone says why don't
you get RFK we've asked him a million
times he's scared okay I'm not trying to
be a dick but we've been told like look
you know we can't do it it's with
respect to Maran Williamson she told us
explicitly like these debates on cable
TV are like we know what they're going
to ask and a show like this you don't
you don't even know I'm like what what
do we do on this show we pull the top
trending news stories and we will talk
about them what's the big story right
now the EP list what else V is saying
he's not going to debate what we got
next Dave Chappelle special if you
cannot talk about the top trending news
you should not be in politics go cry go
run home to your mama because she's
going to she'll she'll comfort you while
you cry and say the man asks me a hard
question have fun what is Aleppo what is
Aleppo this is what this is what they're
scared of but you know the Aleppo
question is perfectly in line with
corporate questions and when when
Johnson couldn't answer that or even
patter effectively well that's said a
lot about his ability to to to navigate
the corporate press but I got to tell
you man when people say things like
these debates should be hosted by like
Joe Rogan or Tucker Carlson and I'm like
they absolutely should and there's a
reason why they won't do it a lot of
this stuff seems like there is still
residual or or a residual effect from
the media being the reliable sources and
I don't think the politicians that or
people that are hoping to to be in
positions of power have caught up to the
fact that there are the portion of the
population that no longer believes the
official narrative specifically because
of Co I mean most people agree that the
average person didn't really need the co
shot there are groups of people that you
know some people don't think any any
covid shot was good some people are like
well you know if you were old or if you
were you know if you had a compromised
immune system then it made sense and
fair enough fine there's room to
disagree I don't care but the point is
because of the inconsistencies because
of the moving goalpost because of the
changing narrative over from from the
from the media and from the government
throughout the whole thing I think that
the people in the US are far more open
to non-official narratives and I think
that the the fact that politicians won't
come to places like this don't want to
go to places like Joe Rogan blah blah
blah I think that's because they're not
they haven't you know assimilated or or
internalized the idea that these places
are important now because the
establishment has hurt their credibility
think about the structure of these
debates on CNN versus what VI wants to
do the structure of these debates on CNN
is
uh Governor Dan santis with immigration
happening in this country is a great
crisis can you tell us why it is that
you have sent migrants to places like
Martha's Vineyard well it's a great
question and I think immigration is a
very important issue now my my administ
in Florida we have the best record when
it comes to schools in our schools 5%
blah blah blah thank you for your
question and then you're like that was
30 seconds and I have no idea what was
said now imagine when uh uh you come on
a show like this there was a point where
people brought up I remember this
specific example that Marian Williamson
didn't answer a question outright and I
just said I kept asking it and then it's
just like you have to answer it cuz like
a conversation can't it's not just that
it's like I asked you a question dude
you didn't answer like I got I'm going
to have to say yes but I asked you this
like these kind of shows demand a higher
quality of politician someone at least
that's capable of actually interacting
with the person in front of them and V
wants to do that V wants to go on the
show where no matter what question you
have for him he's going to answer it yes
and now here here here's the best well I
should say that that is that is the best
part about and probably why someone like
V is doing so well their outright
willingness just to say throw me in the
frying pan and I and I'll succeed
there's a great book called amusing
ourselves to death and it talks about
how the medium completely shapes
everything where we used to be a society
that reads and then we became a society
that watches television now we're
becoming a society that watches podcasts
and so in this new frontier if Trump
weren't in the race vivec ramaswami
would be ahead by 20 points himself
because he's willing to go on Tim cast
he's willing to go on Patrick P David
he's willing to go on Alex Jones and
actually have fully formed conversations
and people see the authenticity and they
see the level of competence you're not
going to get that out of these
establishment shills because they
they're only memorizing 25 second
talking points they're not real all they
care about is making a dollar I want to
stress this point anyone who tells you
that VI is wrong about January 6 being
an inside job is lying to you okay if
you if you don't believe me maybe it's
the first time you've ever heard this
maybe a friend said hey you should
listen to this podcast and you turned it
on and you went that's so crazy it
wasn't an inside job just Google Google
Q Shaman escort watch the video yourself
and then tell me since when is it not an
inside job when law enforcement
facilitating security of the building
assist the people they then later arrest
okay like they they open the door for
these people take selfies with them they
also work in the building for the
government that's what inside job
means that that's it when VI says this
the woman on TV she goes where's your
evidence that the that the Biden
Administration blah blah well hold on
who said anything about this this is the
game they play I'll say something like
January 6 was an inside job oh yeah
what's your proof that Joe Biden
orchestrated January 6 I never said Joe
Biden orchestrated January 6 that was an
inside job they create a fake data point
I've made this example over and over
again about fact Checkers they'll say
you'll watch a video of Donald Trump uh
you know high-fiving Shinzo ab and then
a fact Che did did Donald Trump high
five Shinzo AB dot dot dot on Sunday and
then it'll say false it'll give you this
big long screed about how Donald Trump
did not high five shenzo AB the light
shenzo AB mind you and then at the very
bottom will say well he did high five
them he did not high five them on Sunday
they add that fake information to it did
Shane Cashman appear on Tim cast IRL to
discuss the election Dave Chappelle
taxes and other important American
issues on Monday false he did not it was
Tuesday yeah that's the game they're
playing and so what happens is your
friends and family your liberal aunt and
uncle and cousins watch CNN and CNN is
doing that all day when when VI says
January 6 looks like an inside job then
they come out and they go and VI is
claiming the Biden Administration
orchestrated AR 6 all these people out
of their minds he never said that I
think their magic trick is starting to
fail though like were you were saying
earlier that they changed the center of
gravity they're now calling you
right-wing Tim pool and you're laughing
about it you know they're going to have
to start saying things like extremist
militia leader Tim pool they're going to
have to keep Li they're going to have to
keep saying things that are insane
because the what they're trying to push
nowadays it's mainstream mainstream ABC
to promote a boy chopping his genitals
off now he's a girl thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8: pm and become a member over
at timcast.net